a good example was the the accelerating
universe you know when we found it
evidence for it in 1998 with supernovae
with exploding stars it was great that
there were two teams that
lent some credibility to the discovery
but it was not until
other astrophysicists used not only that
technique
but more importantly other independent
techniques that had their own
potential sources of systematic error or
whatever
but they all came to the same conclusion
and that started
giving a much more complete picture of
what was going on in a picture in which
most astrophysicists quickly gained
confidence
that's why that idea caught on so
quickly is that there were other
physicists and astronomers doing
observations completely independent of
supernovae
that seemed to indicate the same thing
yeah that period of uh
of your life that work with the
incredible team of people
that um won the nobel prize
it's just fascinating work gosh you know
never in my wildest dreams as a kid
did i think that i would be involved
and much less so heavily involved in a
discovery that's so revolutionary i mean
you know
as a kid as a scientist if you're
realistic once you learn a little bit
more about how science is done and
you're not going to win a nobel prize
and be the next
newton or einstein or whatever you just
hope that you'll contribute
something to humankind's understanding
of how nature works and you'll be
satisfied with that
you know but here i was in the right
place at the right time a lot of luck a
lot of hard work
um and there was you know we discovered
something that was really amazing
and that that was the greatest thrill
right i couldn't have asked for anything
more
uh than being involved in that discovery
so one
so the the couple of teams the supernova
cosmology project and the heisi
supernova search team
so that what was the nobel prize given
for it was given for the discovery of
the accelerating expansion of the
universe so maybe
not for the elucidation of what dark
energy is or what causes that expansion
uh that acceleration be it universes on
the outside or whatever
it's just only for the observational
fact so first of all what is the
accelerating universe
so the accelerating universe is simply
that
if we look at the galaxies moving away
from us right now
we would expect them to be moving away
more slowly
than they were billions of years ago and
that's because galaxies have
visible matter which is gravitationally
attractive
and dark matter of an unknown sort that
holds galaxies together
and holds clusters of galaxies together
and of course they then pull on one
another
and they would tend to the
expansion of the universe just as
when i toss an apple up you know even
ignoring
air resistance the mutual gravitational
attraction between earth and the apple
slows the apple down and if that
attraction is great enough then the
apple will someday stop and even come
back
the big crunch you could call it or the
gnab give which is big bang backwards
right
that's what could have happened to the
universe but even if the universe's
original expansion energy was so great
that it avoids the big crunch that's
like an apple thrown at earth's escape
speed it's like the
the the rockets that go to mars someday
right
you know uh with people even then you'd
expect the universe to be slowing down
with time
but we looked back through the history
of the universe by looking at
progressively more distant galaxies
and by seeing the the
evolution of this expansion rate
is that in the first nine billion years
yeah it was slowing down
but in the last five billion years it's
been speeding up
so who asked for that right you know
you